at ms keegan always great to see you do
hope you're well just apologies we can't
be in the same studio during this this
festive week um
let's start with uh with a personal
admission from all of us it's not
feeling very very christmasy uh this
week is it
but the prime minister has said that we
will still be allowed to go with our
christmas parties or on what basis has
he come to that decision
well on the on the basis that you know
we're taking sort of balanced and
proportionate um
approach to it and you know people can
still go ahead and have their christmas
i would disagree actually i had a family
meal yesterday um and it did feel very
christmasy particularly my sister made
it over from the states so uh yeah it's
feeling christmassy families are getting
together sometime for the first time in
nearly three years
i don't know maybe i'm just playing into
the stereotype of the scottish
conversion this morning but let's let's
talk about the data
let's talk about the data though do we
and do we know do we have a figure for
how many people are in hospital at the
moment with omicron
yeah there's a 129 people in hospital
with omicron right now
the the reason i ask and i'm sure you
will be aware of this on the daily brief
the daily update the omicron update it
did suggest that there were some issues
around i.t reporting those those issues
have now been dealt with
well look we're getting data from all
across the country from every hospital
which is being fed up on a daily and
sometimes hourly basis so you know
there's obviously some lags in certain
certain bits of the data but that's the
data that we're collecting 129 people as
of yesterday and 14 deaths with omicron
just in terms of of what is happening do
you feel like we are approaching the
peak of omicron or perhaps have even
peaked but paul hunter from the
university of east anglia suggesting
that numbers may have plateaued we would
have been expecting perhaps if we go on
the growth rate from two weeks ago
perhaps 200 000 cases a day
instead we're reporting around about 90
000.
um no we haven't been given that
information we're watching the data very
very carefully i mean you had three
meetings yesterday where we're all
discussing the data and taking in those
inputs so we don't know that yet um but
we are looking at the wave and we're
looking at all the data and uh we'll
we'll tell you when we think we've
passed peak
so we haven't yet seen a major rise in
hospitalizations if we generalise across
the country but there is there is an
expectation that one is coming though
isn't it
well you know the things that are
unknown which i think we've said a
number of times that they're still
working on is the severity
of the disease and also the impact of
the vaccination and now more importantly
the vaccination plus the booster we know
the booster gives
a huge increase in defense which is why
we're urging everybody and thank you so
much to the nearly 30 million people
who've come forward but for everybody
else if you haven't had your first dose
it really is never too late come forward
start to get yourself and others around
you protected
just in terms of the of the negotiations
well and it feels like there are
negotiations going on around the cabinet
table your boss sanji javid none other
than the health secretary understood to
have been in favor of bringing in
restrictions earlier he told his
colleagues that doing nothing is an is
an active decision but he was he was out
voted do you think he was correct to be
out voted around that table
look you know in the around the cabinet
table obviously you've got to get
everybody with the different views
looking from a different perspective one
will look from health one will look from
the economy one will look from transport
etc and so that's why you have a cabinet
government so you can get all of that
diversity of views and then take a
balanced approach to risk and it is a
difficult decision we do not have all
the information that you would like to
have at your fingertips in particular
as you were talking about earlier the
severity of the disease so it is a
difficult balance but we think we've got
the balance right you know saying to the
country we wanted to lock down et cetera
when you've got those kind of figures
would wouldn't look proportionate so
we're trying to be balanced we're trying
to be proportionate but most importantly
we are monitoring the data um on a on a
daily basis a couple of times a day
actually we get new inputs of data and
that's what we'll continue to do we'll
be working all over christmas and we'll
continue to do that so was the first
minister of scotland wrong to go to go
further than the prime minister then
does she know something that he doesn't
i thought they were working from the
same data set
they are and they have been all the way
through the pandemic but obviously the
devolved administrations have taken
different approaches uh at times and you
know that's their that's their um you
know their authority to be able to do
that um you know people look at the data
the data is no different but i guess uh
the way they analyze the risk could be
different or they look at their
population you know we we've taken a
look at it and we've basically said you
know the hospitalizations the deaths
where we are right now as you said uh
the rising cases whilst the case numbers
are very high um you know they haven't
yet uh reached what was estimated only a
week ago
sure but but just in terms of further
restrictions
it is fair isn't it to say that it's a
question of when and not it
well obviously we've said we have to
keep that option open because you know
we are looking at cases that are going
up at the moment and we are looking at
uh hospitalization which is going up i
was on the program last week and it was
10 then now it's 129. so obviously we do
have to
reserve that option and we won't
hesitate we've said that we will not
hesitate if it's required to keep people
safe but right now the balanced and
proportionate response is we believe the
one that we've put in place
a big announcement in terms of of
isolation for those that are fully
vaccinated at the very least their
self-isolation periods be cut from ten
days to seven
what is the science behind that why are
we now confident that people can be out
you know mixing in the community again
at day seven rather than day ten
well what we've done is looked at
whether serial testing on day six and
day seven uh how that uh the risk of
that uh versus weight until day ten and
effectively they've said it's equivalent
risk if you have day six and day seven
negative tests is equivalent risk to
having another three days in your
bedroom or whatever
but you are asking people who do leave
their homes on
on day seven having had those two
lateral flow tests you are asking them
to minimize social contact you're asking
them to to avoid mixing if at all
possible why is that necessary if it's
safe for them to leave the house on day
seven
we're saying that for everybody we're
saying to everybody look be cautious if
you're going somewhere i mean we we had
a family meal yesterday everyone took a
lateral flow test before make sure you
go to somewhere that's well ventilated
be cautious we're saying that to
everybody you know there's a lot of
unknowns here we still you know don't
have uh all the data that we want um so
be cautious be cautious to enjoy your
christmas
as much as anything else is this perhaps
a means by which we can help out the the
really significant staffing pressures
that there are in the health service at
the moment i mean the bma estimating
between 32 and 130 000 it could be off
work by christmas
yeah i mean that's part of it keeping
the economy going keeping the supply
chains going keeping the nhs going and
keeping yourself going you know
everybody who's uh involved in in
in jobs uh right now
for sure that is part of of looking at
whether uh people can uh with the with
the equivalent risk can uh get back to
work earlier so yes that is part of the
equation
a big package you know inspired the
chance there yesterday a billion pounds
to go to the hospitality sector six
thousand pounds for every individual
business it isn't that a little bit like
trying to fight third world famine with
a packet of frozen peas i mean i spoke
to one venue owner yesterday who said
their daily takings at this time of year
are close to six thousand pounds
yeah sure i mean look what we're not
doing is looking to try and you know
you know
compensate all of that what we're
looking to do is to provide a a security
blanket for businesses like we did all
the way through the pandemic i mean
we've spent 407 billion pounds on on on
businesses and business support so you
know we're just trying to do that for
this period of time we know it's really
unfortunate obviously hitting just
before christmas it is really
unfortunate so to provide that lifeline
and hopefully once we can all get back
out the great british public will do
what they do and they'll support uh all
of these businesses and get back to the
theaters and get back to restaurants
sure but
you described it as a security blanket
if it is such it is pretty threadbare i
mean tim romney chief executive of best
western he says it's just so
disappointing and underwhelming in every
sense it doesn't go far enough opinion
it doesn't go deep enough and it's too
little too late i mean why have we not
reintroduced furlough
well because people are still working i
mean i went out for a family meal
yesterday you know there was the pub was
not every table was full but most of it
was you know people are still going out
and people are still enjoying themselves
so you know we're trying to get that
balance again but actually most
businesses i've spoken to are actually
very appreciative of this support so
obviously you found one there doesn't
think it's enough you'll always find
that but you know this is this is a
billion pounds that we have just
announced and it is there to support
businesses across our country hopefully
for a short period of time until we can
um you know get over this latest uh
variant and the wave of uh disruption
that it's caused
but just in terms of wages because that
clearly has been something that many in
the in the industry have been calling
out for assistance the movement
statutory sick pay helps the funds but
it doesn't help the one in six
hospitality workers perhaps as many as
240 000 people who don't qualify for it
well i mean it's there again for those
smaller firms um to make sure that
people can self-isolate for up to two
weeks the government will pay um and you
know it's it's it's been very welcomed i
think from from most of the businesses
that uh i've spoken to him from what
i've heard as well you know this is
something again we're dealing with
uncertainty we've responded really
quickly to this latest uncertainty we
hope it doesn't last too long but that
is uh as you know a billion pounds
that's been announced and it is not
something that should be dismissed it's
something that i think largely is
welcomed
minister let's let's return to the top
of our interview
where i you know self-describe myself as
a bit of a grumpy scot perhaps you can
lift my mood i mean in your mind
on the basis of the the limits that
people are already putting on their own
activity as you mentioned you know
you're in a restaurant yesterday and not
all the tables were used in your mind if
we carry on on this path and people keep
doing what they are doing is there any
chance
any chance whatsoever that we might not
see that circuit breaker lockdown that
frankly everyone is predicting
again you know we as i've said we're
waiting for data on the severity we'll
still have to wait to see
um you know where we land on that but um
we can't really say you know we've said
is up to christmas we're fine looking at
the data looking at the the numbers we
have at the moment but of course we have
to look at where this virus goes where
this variant goes so we have to look at
that data i can't tell you in advance of
getting that data but you should be
cheerful because we're doing a lot more
than we could last year we're able to
see our family as i said i have my
sister and her family over from the
states we haven't seen them for nearly
three years so lots of people are
getting to see family members that they
haven't seen for a long time and lots of
us will get together with our loved ones
at christmas
julian keegan lovely to have you on the
program and you make sure you have a
lovely christmas when it comes
you too happy christmas and cheer up